hôm nay mình lại quay trở lại kiểu làm
đồ án này đúng ạ dán này cũng hơi hơi
chậm nói chậm tiến độ một tí là hãy là
mình lấy cái này đang lẽ phải cơ hội
chữa tôi xem cho có sinh viên nào đơn
giản làm tuần là xong Bây giờ chỉ cô ấy
rồi à U45 buổi là mỗi cái thêm nhỉ Sửa
mình có cho làm sửa xóa cơ thì là mũi
thêm rồi đấy em ạ mất thời gian phết I
Ờ Ờ
hôm nay thì mình muốn chuyển qua cái cho
đỡ nhàm chán hơn là mình sẽ làm cái hiển
thị mình sẽ kiểu hiển thị ra
cho tỷ giá cái mà mình hôm trước mình
hay thêm không ạ
em mới gọi Hiển thị các bài đăng có
hướng sẽ hiển thị ra trông sẽ như thế
nào nhưng mà chưa hết thì ngoài tâm sự
tí đã
nói cái vụ này cho mấy ông chắc là tôi
nghĩ là có phải ông mình sẽ xem có không
phải ông nào cũng ngồi xem trực tiếp cho
mày ông sẽ xem lại thôi Có gì thế
ở nhà thuộc xã tôi sẽ nói mấy cái này
trước đã xong rồi nói cái này cuối cùng
cái này ngày cuối cùng
đầu tiên thì
ở trên này Hôm qua khi mà tôi thấy có
một tin ra tin đấy nó tin à
cô tin đấy trước hả Tiên Phong vui nó
khi mà tôi thấy à có một vụ tai nạn ở
Ừ ừ
Cát Bà
đúng đúng cái chỗ mà tôi vừa mới đi du
lịch hôm trước thì hôm nay Mới mười hung
hôm qua mới có về vụ tai nạn ở đấy
Ừ thì à Lúc đấy thì đột nhiên tôi lại ở
bật ra câu nói mà tôi nghĩ à à Tôi học
theo từng người khác tôi nhớ Tôi học
theo từng người khác sao tôi mình nghĩ
lại đó là tôi bảo là mai mai mà mình
không mà mình kiểu Hôm hôm mình đi Khởi
làm sao
ờ ờ
cái thực ra thì những ông không biết mấy
ông của như thế không mấy ông thỉnh
thoảng mà
Ê mấy ông có thỉnh thoảng kiểu khi mà
khi mà kiểu thấy một cái chuyện thì nó
bất ngờ xảy ra thì ông cảm thấy may mắn
khi mà mình không phải không không không
bị như thế nhớ thực ra thì nó làm cái
Mai nó lại dựa trên sự mất mát người
khác thì tôi nghĩ à Đôi khi đôi khi con
người mình thường hay vẫn bị có một cái
thói quen là như thế đó chúng ta hãy so
sánh mình với người khác và cảm thấy ví
dụ ví dụ là sự nếu xung quanh của xung
quanh của ông Tất cả đều
em đều nghèo ông lại thấy giờ ở bình
thường ông ông sẽ không có khó chịu gì
cả nhưng mà đột nhiên mà
có rất nhiều dầu hơn những người xung
quanh ở ngoại cảm thấy mình mét mà nước
những người sống ngoài cái kiểu thế hoa
ngược lại nó lại em sẽ thế nếu mà xung
quanh đều dầu mỗi mình ông nghèo thì ông
sẽ nghĩ rằng nhà mình để đủ hai mình nói
chung à không phải đen đổi mà kiểu dáng
mà mình tệ hơn những người xung quanh và
Vân ngoạn có nghĩa là cuộc sống hay đó
nhưng mình nên có sự so sánh để mình nên
có một sự thật là con người mình mà
không có lòng tham không có kiểu dạng là
so sánh mình với người khác
em không có tính lạnh hả Lúc nào cũng
kiểu đều đều bằng bằng ấy thì ra ở cuộc
sống hơi nhàm chán nó không có đối xanh
gì cả
ông ngoại chúng ta phải cũng có tí làm
hai mình chúng ta mới phát triển như
ngày mai không phải chúng ta Chắc là
sống ở trong hang mới hết cả lũ rồi thấy
rõ và không ham không đòi hỏi thêm cái
gì cả thì chỉ có thể vẫn là thời kỳ đồ
đá thôi
lúc thì mình không nên cậu
còn là nha nhé Nếu có thể thì không nên
dẫm đạp lên người khác để mình tồn tại
hai để để mà cảm thấy May hơn người khác
vì những cái trường hợp như thế có nghĩa
như thế ế
à À cái thỉnh thoảng tôi Tâm sự cái này
nó hơi bị chết học một tí hơi bị triết
lý một tí thông cảm tôi không còn lo
nghĩ kiểu như thế nghĩa là nếu mình
mà những
Thì đại khái mình không so sánh rồi mấy
cái việc may mắn nhiều như thế như nó là
một sự mất mát mà không
ừ ừ
Ừ
ok và một cái nữa là tôi có thỉnh thoảng
hay đang tâm sự ở trên
A Di Tru Tiên có 10 tỷ
Ừ nếu không mấy ông ở bên chưa từng có
mấy thì sẽ thấy thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ
thường ai đang bày kiểu dạng à Khi mà
mình ngủ dậy mình sẽ xóa bình luận có
chữ số sao
có trước thì tội từng làm tool để mà để
mà tự động xã hội cho tôi cứ đúng 7 giờ
sáng sẽ tự động xóa
em ngồi đây tôi ngồi một Facebook khá
nhiều Và tôi cảm thấy cái gì mà nó Nó
kiểu bị lập Điệp lại như thế sẽ làm hết
tun
anh béo hiểu nhé vận dụng kiến thức Mình
đã học kết hợp tín hiệu api Facebook sau
đó thì mình làm thôi Ngôn ngữ nạn được
ra Swift pp cũng được đấy thì
Ừ thì à lúc đấy tôi đã trau dồi được
thêm khá nhiều kiến thức về việc là mình
làm tôn Facebook khá nhiều cũng tìm hiểu
khá nhiều thứ tìm hiểu cụ thể kia chẳng
hạn đấy nhưng mà đến bây giờ thì tôi là
không
À thỉnh thoảng tôi không chạy bằng tool
nữa Tôi xóa băng chạy bằng cơm hàng ở
lớp tôi cái thức huyện tôi dậy muộn quá
không Béo ngấy kiện nhưng mà nhưng mà
tôi chả đến cái ngưỡng mà thỉnh thoảng
tôi thích làm cái gì ở thủ công không
thích kiểu máy móc không thấy kiểu công
nghiệp đã tôi không thấy chạy bằng tool
nữa nhưng mà còn bây giờ thì mấy ông còn
đang Vợ đang mới mẻ đang mới học đấy thì
mới là tôi nghĩ em mấy ông bắt chước tôi
là thực hành nhiều thực hành làm cái
thấy cái gì mà mà Nó kiểu nó bị trùng
lặp lại làm một công việc như thế mấy
ông thử nghĩ xem mà mình có thể cần dùng
lập trình để can thiệp điều này nó không
có thể nó tốn thời gian hơn đấy nó tốn
thời gian hơn
em ngồi cốt cái đoạn đấy có thể mất 34
ngày thì nó ngồi làm một tiếng sau Nhưng
mà về sau nếu mà ông gặp lại các trường
hợp đấy không chỉ được chạy cái rồi ngồi
ngắm những dòng cố đồng chạy Thế là xong
nó sự tự động làm xong hết cho mình
ngoại và nó sẽ cải thiện được kỹ năng
của mình bởi vì mình có thứ là mình
ở Pháp dụng và màn gọn mịn và đặc biệt
là mình sẽ thích thú hơn về lập trình
hồi nãy tôi làm nhiều ăn làm nhiều tôn
lắm từ tôn tài và bộ ảnh hãy toàn vụ như
giao Vân từng khoe với ông tôi thì thì
tôi cài tôi còn thiết lập trình hơn
Ừ ok và bây giờ cho nó nói nốt cái cuối
này
hôm hung cũng hôm trước tôi có nghĩ về
vụ này đó là nhất là ở tôi hiện từng hứa
cho mấy ông là khi mà làm xong đồ án
thì tôi sẽ thường cái gì đó ngoại lệ tới
thưởng nhà tôi cho cái kèo hẹn đi cà phê
vậy hãy gì đó nhưng mà béo tôi nghĩ có
một cái hay hơn bản chất là tôi đang có
khá nhiều tài liệu Tôi tự mua và cũng đi
tại từ khá như nguồn nhưng mà cái tài
liệu đấy
em có cả tài liệu dành cho người mới
nhưng mà cũng có tài liệu rất nhiều tài
liệu là dành cho Suneo Suneo không phải
facile thì những cái liệu đấy Thực ra
thứ nhất thứ nhất đó là nó nó thường nó
bắt phí nên là
cho nên là tôi không muốn chia sẻ một
cách kiểu khá là bừa bãi cho mấy ông
theo kiểu là cứ chia sẻ thằng đây như
thế này nó dễ bị ăn bản quyền cũng như
là không tôn trọng nó ra Nhưng mà nếu
còn chia sẻ một vài cá nhân thì không xa
nghe tôi nghĩa là tôi
Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ giới hạn lại bằng
cách đó như thế này đó là
mấy ông tất cả mấy ông kể cả mấy ông
không làm đồ án đi chăng nữa với ông học
của tôi và ra đại khá vào trong cái
server discord của tôi dừng ạ xong rồi
mấy ông chỉ cần nói chung có học của tôi
xác nhận đã có học của tôi bằng cách
thật kia thì
nếu không có thể nhắn tin cho tôi
về à mã xác nhận cho làm với ông đã đi
thực tập ai dám chỉ là giống như cái
trường cũ rồi ấy hiểu phải xin cái giấy
xác nhận đi học tập Đấy là đã đi làm
theo ngành này ấy thì thì tôi hoàn toàn
tôi sẽ có thì họ thêm ong vào cài drive
của tôi đang có chứa những tài liệu kia
thì mới ông có thể một phần hưởng là mấy
ông ra thích thì mấy ông có thể mua được
nữa
em tự mua cũng được nhưng mà bây giờ có
thêm tài liệu thì mới ông sẽ càng thấy
bộ hơn không ạ tốt hơn chứ tôi giữ một
mình tôi rồi đọc cũng chẳng để làm gì
tôi thích chia sẻ mà
Ừ nhưng mà Bởi vì anh như tôi nói nó là
mất phí đó là dính đến bản quyền nên này
Giờ tôi không để chia sẻ dễ dãi được nói
cho mấy ông nếu những ông nào cần thì có
thể inbox Có tôi nói cho nó đã xác nhận
được đi làm theo mình này nóng bạn thì
nó nó đúng người đúng đối tượng ngoại
tôi sẽ gửi mấy ông cũng như việc là tôi
gửi cho mấy ông kiểu như thế sẽ tránh
rủi ro việc không thể đem đi đăng nó
khác thì bán ở nữa khác thứ Jack à Nó
chỉ như tôi không có tôi không lưu mình
cái đấy Tôi không theo khác thì như là
tôi nhớ là hồi trước giờ chưa tìm công
ty từng chia sẻ
Ừ nhưng mà Đấy tài liệu miễn phí mẹ ạ
đấy bỏ qua tại miễn phí trên mạng đây Ờ
ờ ờ những cái buổi học đồ án web này thì
tôi sẽ không tôi sẽ không thông báo trên
xe với cốt
của của tôi bởi vì cái ở đây mày không
phải hiểu của thận 2 server 1server là
server Server này là server
school này là là tôi dậy bình thường nhé
là một server để là của tôi số phone này
là để cho mình ông vào để mà làm đồ án
thì có hai cái server như thế những cái
gì đến đâu án thì tôi xuất tinh ở trên
cái đồ án còn cái dạy bình thường thì
tôi tinh cái nhóm servo bình thường thôi
ờ ờ đấy đợi Thái thứ nhất thứ nhất vừa
rồi Tôi nói là như thế đó làm chị là tôi
có tài liệu gì tôi sẽ chia sẻ bà cái thứ
hai thậm chữ cái con cũng hay đó là nhóm
những cái bạn kia thì
về bản chất bản chất có một sự thật này
cho mấy ông có thể có mấy ông biết rồi
đó chứ k mấy ông không nên tự trực tiếp
đi xin việc
em thật sự như thế đến giờ năm ngoái rồi
Ừ ok em
ờ ờ Nếu không lên trực tiếp kiểu nộp hồ
sơ vào một công ty ở đó áo kiểu để mà
kiểu người ta Tuyển mấy ông Tại sao
anh Bởi vì a mấy ông có một sự thật là
nếu mấy ông mà thông qua một bạn hát rồi
mà bạn tuyển dụng nào đó mà bạn nó giới
thiệu thì bạn giới thiệu khi sẽ được ăn
hoa hồng À như thế nếu mà khi mà ông
nhận được việc còn mấy ông bé ông tiền
hẳn như thế thì mấy ông về các bạn chả
được cái gì vậy
Cho nên nếu thế tôi đang nghĩ là nó cũng
mua sự hay ho ở đây đó là là nếu có thể
thăm qua tôi rồi tôi sẽ
khi gà chọi từng nói vụ tôi không nhận
tiền rồi nghe tôi sẽ có cách này đó là
ý là tôi sẽ dùng cái tiền hoa hồng đấy
mục chuyện chắc ở một nó chia sẻ lại cho
mấy ông kia gửi lại với ông hay là sẽ
mua tài liệu để mà để mà
cũng chả đương nhiên là vẫn để chia sẻ
không thấy ông ngồi mà Mấy ông hoàn toàn
thể
A gọi như nào nhé
à Tôi đang nghĩ là kiểu dạng cho mấy ông
bầu
mà mình hướng đến ở nên mua tài liệu Đây
là tài liệu inbox nhé quyển sách gì đâu
à Tôi đang hướng đến là như thế Em chỉ
là
em nói nó tóm tắt mày không dễ hình dung
nhé nó Nó là kiểu dạng là mấy ông bình
thường mà ông sẽ xin
sau khi mà ông được tuyển thẳng đúng
không Ờ
sau khi mà ông được tiền hàng thì mới
ông sẽ không được một cái cái tiền hoa
hồng gì cả khi mà người nhận việc còn
nếu mà bạn Hấp rồi Hoặc à một bạn nào đó
giới thiệu với ông và công ty mấy ông
nói chuyện ấy thì mấy bạn đấy sẽ được
tiền hoa hồng đúng không Nếu Nhà tôi ở
tôi từng tầng bảo tôi sẽ không muốn làm
gì liên quan đến tiền bạc gì mấy ông cả
niềm cách hay hơn thì có ông nào giữ hội
tôi tiền càng tốt
số tiền đó thì chắc là tôi sẽ công khai
và và sẽ cứ cho vòng cái gọi là quy à
anh cái gì đó để mà Mấy ông hoàn toàn Có
thể cậu
anh nói chung ở biết được cái quy công
khai bao nhiêu tiền và kết hợp lượng là
là mình sẽ
cho mình mình sẽ đề xuất Buồn cái ebook
mà đó
Ừ nếu mình do xong rồi để mà có thể chia
sẻ cho anh em
tôi là mày Ông sắp Nói chung là làm thế
nào xa nhận được mà béo đi thực tập hay
là đang đi làm ở đâu Ở đó mà đã khoa học
của tôi tôi sẽ chia sẻ tài liệu ông ấy
tôi chẳng mất gì cả
Vẫn Mong mà Mấy ông kiểu nên giữ cho
mình Thư không nên đi chia sẻ nhiều quá
nó không tôn trọng tác giả cũng nhờ cái
sau mà dính bản quyền lại quay ở kiện
tôi mệt
Hôm nay tôi tôi đang hướng đến là như
thế Tôi không biết được là làm thấy có
cái gì sai không và kiểu ôm mới chỉ có ý
tưởng hay như thế thôi Chưa nghĩ gì hơn
mấy ông có thể
có đóng góp gì thêm thì mày không có gì
nhắn tin tôi sau nhé
khi chúng tôi nghĩ là thực ra là nó liên
quan đến tiền bạc ra khá Rắc Rối thứ mà
tôi luôn tránh rồi nhưng mà
ạ Bây giờ nếu mà để mà tôi
khi tôi bỏ tiền túi ra đi mua tài liệu
liên tục để chia sẻ với ông ấy nó cũng
tốn kém phải dùng từ không tốn kém
ờ ờ còn
và đặc biệt là mấy ông Khi mà mới ông
kiểu Bởi vì bây giờ có rất nhiều bạn Hấp
rồi nhắn tin cho tôi à kiểu là bây giờ
giới thiệu cho cho chị cầu một vài bạn
nào đó đúng
cho mấy bạn xong rồi mấy ông vào được
được được nhận việc thì rõ là mấy chị ấy
trả hoa hồng cho mình mình không nhận
này là thiệp mình phải rõ ra mấy bạn
kiệm sẽ được
nha mình Nếu mình được thì mình cứ nhận
thôi Đúng
Ê bà Quan trọng là nhận nhận không phải
để ăn tiêu mà nhận để mà kiểu mình lại
mua thêm tài liệu sau đó chia sẻ cho các
bạn khác nữa thì càng tốt ngoạn tôi tôi
nghĩa là nó là kiểu dạng là một vòng lặp
đi nó kiểu dạng làm người đi trước sẽ để
lại những cái thứ cho người
đi sau người đi sau cũng công hưởng xong
rồi nó lại cảnh nhân nhân rộng lên thì
nó khá ổn Tôi đang nghĩ như thế
hyphal học xong mà học cái khóa của tôi
facile luôn hạ chí ở Junior luôn ấy cần
gì kiểu in tơ mà mình nữa người bản chất
là làm xong cái đồ án thì mấy ông cũng
nằm chắc được khá nhiều thông tin được
ờ ờ
ạ Bây giờ tôi tiện thôi Nói Cái vụ
theo nhóm
nhắn tin cho nhau giao công việc kiểu
thủ công tôi khuya là mấy ông lên kiểu
dùng challo hoặc cả dùng một cái cũng cụ
ở đó tưởng như này để mà kiểu quản lý
mình tiến trình đang làm đến đâu từ a
đến z gì đâu Cái làm việc là chỗ gửi
được cho người kia ấy
em sửa lỗi này
Ừ đợi tí đợi
Ừ thì tôi tới nghĩa là mấy ông lên à à
Ừ tối khuya nằm đâu nên dùng có thể chơi
lâu nha trở lại chiều khá tiện này a cho
cậu nha tôi thì ví dụ ông nhá Nó sẽ cho
dự định đang làm gì ta đã gì mà bận rộn
ngay xong rồi có thể thêm rất nhiều cái
như thế này tích và những cái kiểu đã
hoàn thành như này nó dơ tiện đấy thì
mấy ông làm như này thì mấy ông nội có
khoa học để bảo quản lý công việc đã bạn
ba làm giờ đến đâu cần phải làm gì tiếp
cho Vân đấy thì và đặc biệt là mấy ông
có thể chụp lại hoặc là thêm tôi vào
những cái Cello như thế này thêm Ngoài
ra tôi không thích hẳn thêm đâu thêm tôi
vào bị nhiều cái chơi đẹp quá nhau mấy
ông hệ chụp lại là mấy ông đang tiến
trình là đang làm đến đâu đến đâu còn
những bước nào thì Mà tôi cũng nắm được
và nhóm của mấy ông
đã làm xong cái gì chưa Làm xong cái gì
con vân nó cũng gửi cho ông ạ
em chưa bây giờ thực sự thì nhóm các bạn
bây giờ đang làm đồ ăn hay nó có rất
nhiều tính năng mà Mấy ông chỉ ngồi ghi
ra word xong cái ông làm đi đâu chả nhớ
đang làm đến đoạn nào và mấy ông cũng
không có chú thích gì cả thỉnh thoảng
mấy ông nếu không có ý tưởng tôi khi mà
đang làm dở Cái gì đâu có nhiều ý tưởng
á sẽ phải ghi thêm ra nốt thêm ở một đâu
đó thì chia lô một cái ra phù hợp để em
Nếu không phải nói lại những cái kiểu ý
tưởng cũng như là cách giải quyết nó như
thế nào bởi vì đôi khi mình như ý tưởng
trước mình cũng bắt tay vào làm đúng
không
Ở đây có nghĩa là mấy ông đang cần cái
này
Ừ ừ tiếp theo nữa
vì nó có bạn hôm trước hỏi là có nên
dùng audi0 ao của thằng nào Eo ý thì cái
hôm trước đến bây giờ tôi hình như vẫn
chưa chạy vào ở trên máy thôi Tôi không
hiểu sao Ờ nhưng mà tôi khuyên là mấy
ông nên dùng
anh Bởi vì cho nó thường nó gắn liền với
các packet khác của thằng Model Nếu có
liên quan với nhau để mà kiểu mình tối
như cá thứ Còn nếu không thì ông sẽ phải
tự cố tuần mà có thuần thế khi mà ông
cài thêm vài cho bác ít mà liên quan đến
thằng này kéo lại phải sửa lại khác nằm
có nghĩa là nếu mà có thể mình nên dùng
cái có sẵn nó Nếu chạy được tôi Tôi chưa
hiểu sao không được của tôi ra có khi
phải nhảy sang dùng season thuần cho nó
cho nó cơ bản
tạm thời Thế
ờ ờ
Ý là hôm trước hôm trước mình cho tôi
hướng dẫn này ông về cách code đẩy cốt
lên bằng get desktop chứ nhỉ
em đặt đôi một tí
giả sử mặc định của ông chỉ có mỗi cái
main thôi chẳng ạ Ông hoàn toàn có thể
quét
có main thôi chẳng hạn đúng không ạ
Ừ thì ông ông có thể là ông không không
không Nếu một người làm thì đẩy Cốt Đây
nó khác nếu mà nhiều người làm thì cũng
sẽ có thể tạo một quay mở như thế này
một là giả sử là ông chỉ làm một việc
một lúc thì ông hoàn toàn để đặt tên
quen là tên của chính ông đấy thế là
được đấy Xong rồi ông sẽ cốt hết ở trên
quen này thôi và cốt những cái dở dang
cũng ở trên span đấy ông sẽ đầy hết lên
trên ngực lên đấy sau đó khi mà cốt xong
hoàn thành xong một cái gì đó rồi thì
ông sẽ có mất quay này lên tạo một cái
tôi đừng nên đặt tên là cái cục pin danh
của bản thân mình như thế này nói xong
rồi tôi hoàn toàn thể cốt bao nhiêu tôi
sẽ đầy lên là friend like nhưng mà đây
là bao gồm cả những cái chưa hoàn thiện
chưa hoàn thiện cũng đẩy lên đây sau đó
thì
hai iPhone xách cột chống xem nhé
à à
chủ nhà trắng nó ngày đúng không
thì mình sẽ có cá test nha Chẳng ngon
Ừ ông có thể đẩy hết lên cực quen này là
như thế này khi chưa
Sau đó thì ông hoàn toàn thể hiểu Giả sử
ông cốt sao mười gì đó rồi ông thể gọi
là cherry-pick ở đây ông thể chọn rất
nhiều ship phải chọn nhiều hoa ông thể
kéo ra như thế này để mà ông muốn mất
mỗi cái này xanh đấy trong trường hợp mà
ông muốn mất Mỗi cái đấy con giờ sửa ông
muốn mất hết thì ông sẽ sang bên này
xong rồi ấn ở đây có phím tắt và can
thiệp mời
anh hiểu không mất toàn bộ cái cái kia
vào như thế này
ở đây đây là cách để mà ông tạp ren nữa
Tại một nhánh riêng để móng cốt xong sẽ
mất toàn bộ ngành đấy vào trong cảnh
hành chính đấy Sao trở nhánh này đều có
tất cả những cái ổn rồi còn nếu mà giờ
sử mà như tôi bảo là giờ sửa ông có rất
nhiều cái trong này ông chỉ muốn đẩy một
vài cái Giả sử những cái này thôi Nếu sẽ
kéo chơi Pi kiểu nhà truyền xa như thế
này như thế này chưa
À thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ bị cái lỗi konflik
ngay bởi vì à
thằng cùng chung một cái vừa rồi mà
Nụ Cười
à
hay là cùng trung tại cùng chung cái rồi
bố con thích nhỉ
xe hơi lạ
Ừ đấy nhưng đại khái như thế đó là cách
để mà ông cốt trùng tương đối với các ít
đấy chị ạ mà Cái quan trọng là là là lúc
mà trước khi ông đầy cốt này lên nhá ông
phải luôn để xanh cà phê này sau đó thì
ông update ông fake để mà lấy cốt mới đó
Ông xã về nhanh cũ ăn ông ăn control
seepoo ngay để ông cập nhật cốt mới từ
cái nhánh quen à nhánh hành chính về
trước khi ông ông mất lên cốt bên cạnh
anh chính nếu cái hình dung nha
khi gà tôi cũng chưa chuyên phải get lắm
em Tôi nghĩ là tôi đang dạy mấy ông cái
khác bạn ý thôi
hiểu đấy
ở đại hải mấy ông cứ hình dung tư duy ở
như thế này thằng ngày tháng chính mấy
thằng quen là mấy thằng nhánh mấy thằng
con đúng không Thì mấy ông luôn phải thứ
nhất ở luôn mày không có hình dung hàng
nên lại phải luôn có cút xịn luôn có có
chạy được luôn có chạy đúng đã thằng
main này phải luôn có cốt kiểu
cả hai thùng thôi nha Nói chung một cốc
không có bất Vì cả ở trên này để làm gì
đề mà ông sẽ luôn lấy cốt từ cái nhanh
đấy về xong rồi ông làm xong rồi ông làm
xong rồi Khi mà chắc chắn ở ông làm xong
không có bất thì rồi ông ấy được phép
đẩy lên cái nhãn này đấy đấy cách quy
trình hiện tại ở công ty tôi như nghĩa ở
công ty tôi như thế nhiều công ty ở xe
khác kiểu ông ông đầy ông lấy cốt từ cái
nhánh nó không Không có vấn đề gì cả về
cho ông ngồi Cốt
ạ sau đó thì ông ông phải luôn liên tục
lấy cốt từ đây về nhá Tránh trường hợp
và kiểu ông bảy đầu cốt lên nó xung đột
với cốc nồi khác nó không sẽ luôn lấy về
thôi ông cốt xong chán chê rồi ông khi
ông test xong các thứ thứ thúc đẩy lên
nhanh chính nếu thế nó sẽ khá sáng mấy
cái trường hợp con click và cũng như
Tránh trường hợp và ông chị có trên một
cặp gen tạm thời tôi chỉ dậy được mấy
ông cơ bản thì thôi
nó sẽ có kiểu kiểu lâu khác nhau
về giá xe máy đầu tiên
khá
em có hình dung đây ở nhà nó có hot nick
này đi vào lớp này Ừ cái này cái này thì
nó hơi nâng cao hơn cho cái tôi của nó
nhưng cái này lâu này là đúng đấy
Ừ
cái này là Nhưng mà cái này làm chị à
khi móng cốt nhảy sang là cô Thắm cái dự
án nó có liên quan được có trên rồi
nghĩa là dự án thực tế rồi thì nó sẽ
khái niện và Master sẽ chỉ luôn chứa
những cái phiên bản xịn này đấy
vài lúc là kiểu đang chạy mà cần phải
sửa gì đó nhanh thì sẽ khái niệm hotfix
những mình sẽ tạo 1 Red hot wok để mình
sửa gì đó nhanh sau đó mình sẽ đẩy đẩy
lên đẩy lên luôn sửa sao mình phải để
luôn
à
Còn Diva lốp thì tức à tất cả các nhánh
mà để mình test mình sẽ có 1 nơi chỉ có
cốt xịn mà Trang web chính thức của mình
và một trang chuyên để test thôi là mình
sẽ cốt bao nhiêu mình sẽ đẩy hết lên cây
xanh đấy test nghĩa là mình sẽ có bao
gồm và test ở local là két rồi ở trên
máy tính cá nhân sau đó thì mình sẽ đẩy
hết cốc lên cái á
a a cái đẹp này để mà Tết thêm một lần
nữa cái cái đẹp này nó sẽ có môi trường
khá giống rồi cái Master nhưng mà dữ
liệu lại dữ liệu là là đét đấy sập và
những cái tính năng của mấy ông làm sẽ
những cái nhánh kiểu Pixel kiểu như này
đỡ ông hoàn toàn là ông sẽ lấy lấy cốt
thứ 1 là ông ấy có từ chính nét về để
ông ông có tiếp hay là ông sẽ nhảy lấy
cốt từ chính Master ở trên công ty tôi
lấy có từ chỉnh Master vì codad bây giờ
nó khá là khả giường Già Và nó có rất
nhiều bất ở trên kế cốt đẹp này nghe
thường tôi vẫn Bọn tôi làm lấy có từ
Master về để nó cốt luôn là không có lỗi
sau đó tôi mới bắt đầu bọn tôi mới cốt
sau đó Bọn tôi lại mất vào trong bếp
ạ sau đó thì khi mà test xong các thứ
thử rồi thực ra là dàn ở một vài công ty
nữa nó còn thêm một nhánh nữa làn nhánh
Nha tekinh te kinh
anh như này nó là một nhánh mà nó môi
trường nó cũng làm Watson Và nó có 300
bay cũng mà còn non từ cái Braxin nghĩa
là dữ liệu dữ liệu thật
khi bé ông hiểu không Chẳng qua nó sẽ
không phải là cái bản để cho khách hàng
chạy ở trên đấy mà do chính lập trình
viên mình chạy trên đấy xem à code của
mình để với dữ liệu vừa Trần có vấn đề
gì không Trước khi mình thực sự đã đẩy
lên thành phố Busan là bậy hàng nên dự
án thực tế
Ừ cái này thì tôi Nghĩa đi làm một công
ty nó sẽ còn kiểu khác nhau nữa thôi Chỉ
em nói qua cho bé bằng máu hình chung về
việc là cách cốt như nào sau cháu tổ
chức các thứ thứ lục luôn làm việc nghe
thôi nó hợp lý
tối thiểu Aeon Bình thường là sẽ là là
lấy cốt tử đẹp đúng không tặng When từ
ghép để mà cô chú ý trời đúng không
Nhưng mà bản chất là cái bếp ở công ty
tôi nó sẽ bao gồm các test nữa Chiều
mình đẩy lên đấy à tết đấy anh ra nó sẽ
có rất nhiều bất nó nó chưa được kích
nên thành ra là
Anh thành ra là kiểu kéo dãn công ty tôi
làm chơi kiểu dạng lấy đôi mắt tôi nhưng
là có nhiều cũng có một nhịp điểm Đấy là
nếu là 2 trường trường hợp mà hai hai
người cùng cốt một cái mô đun đấy thì
nếu mà khi mà mới lên Dash một lần nữa
này test thì nó sẽ dễ bị cong Phước
Ừ nhưng mà ở công ty tôi người ra lại ít
ý anh em kiểu cốt cùng một cái mô đun
hiện tại công ty vẫn đang ít người vẫn
chơi cái này được còn về sau nếu mà đông
hơn đông hơn thì thì nó sẽ dễ bị Compaq
Future đấy đã test các cửa thứ chắc chắn
rồi để đẩy lên nét và nó đúng không
ở cây cái á cái đấy trong trường hợp mấy
ông test ở trên máy nó chuẩn sẵn rồi thì
lên lên nét và gần như là nó chẳng làm
gì mấy mà mình phải tái lại một lần nữa
thì không sao để không sao
mà đúng không Mình sẽ phải lựa xem mà nó
phù hợp với với của mình hay không
Ừ nhớ mà cơ bản thì nó vẫn cái cơ bản
luồng làm việc ấy thì vẫn ở đấy dễ mình
nên tạo những cặp gen riêng để mà làm và
mình hiểu rõ là từng quen nó có những
cái Nhiệm vụ là như thế nào Tại sao lại
tạo những claire như thế Nó ngoan chứ
không phải là mấy ông dùng hết chung một
cái quen là một trong những cái sai này
không ạ hoa cả không hiểu về những cái
quen đấy khi đi làm Nếu không sẽ bị bỡ
ngỡ Tôi vừa rồi nó qua như thế
ừ ừ
anh lại đòi yêu cầu nhắn gì con nữa
Ừ ok
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ bây giờ cho mấy câu này mình sẽ nói
cụ thể hơn ở trong những cái bài Sau Còn
bây giờ thì mình muốn là hôm nay mình
muốn thư giãn một tí Mình sẽ ngồi làm
giao diện
giao diện không giúp sinh sản nó dễ cắt
hành ở
mình là
Ờ Ờ
bây giờ sự là mình sẽ hiển thị ra những
cái bài bài đăng đầu tiên là
ở đầu tiên là tôi sẽ cần giao diện đã ở
ngọn thì tôi nhớ Tôi từng chia sẻ với
ông rồi cái A
cái tách khỏi đây này đây Ừ cái này có
rất nhiều giao diện ở đây thì để để biết
trước được giao diện nào trong phù hợp
với mình thì mình sẽ tra tên của nó đã
bạn nên nhớ là cái này là bút Chắc ba
nếu mà ông cha đưa đôi khi nó khá là cũ
và nó nhảy cho bút chap 4 rồi ông phải
tìm lại bước cho bà cũng xem nhé Rồi
ghét ít ăn
ngay Ông bảo thuê thêm chút Pretty và
năm trước nữa Để để nó tránh với team A
nhé Ông có thể pro nữa Nói chung cái này
hồi mua Black Friday đi khám tốn tiền
đấy Cái này Tổng anh em phải góp chung
vào đấy
gồm cả thị này
À hôm crock-pot để xem để xem thử nhé
ạ Mình làm gì có sao chứ đúng không
Ừ cái này ảnh nền nhà mình chẳng có ảnh
nền luôn đi
ở nơi xa ngân hàng mình hình như mình
không có vụ anh lên sao
ở bài đăng của mình vẫn đang của mình sẽ
chỉ có
mục tiêu đề không có ảnh
a Company các thứ thứ ở không ảnh ở
trong được chồng à
Ê mày có giao diện cả nhà chạy được rồi
đúng
ở lại giao diện cửa nhà này chả đấy Cái
được
em xin Linh lại cái cái này tối chia sẻ
ở trên cái server decody
kênh tài liệu ấy nếu ông vào xe tôi tôi
bán hết trong đấy mà à
mình hiển thị giao diện cái này trong
kiểu gì nhỉ
Ừ đợi thì một là ông ốp luôn ngay cái
đầu này hay mấy ông thể xem những ai nữa
có cạn nếu mà nó ghi chữ view của họ ghi
Christie hai cái A ghi cái rồi Yeah kiểu
nha à
Ừ thì tất cả nó nó dùng được cho cả mấy
cái khách là ít
A
Z và view
nếu mà nó ghi HTML thuần như thế này thì
sẽ là kiểu mình chị ôm Thuần về được
đầu tiên đi nhé
em xem bộ
Ừ cái này là
ngày thôi thì mình sẽ thiết kế lại cho
cái này không phải là ảnh ờ
Anh cần gì ảnh
Vì sao
của các bạn đấy Gửi tôi có ảnh đâu Làm
sao mình lấy được ảnh
thôi
dù có mất tới rô có
Vì sao mà ông muốn dùng mơ thấy Đò
có ai motor key pro này à
ừ ừ
từ ngày 1.11 trắng để version 2 rồi
anh nhìn ra đầu thú Long chap 14.5 rồi à
ạ bây hệ Vũ chap 4 - 3G của tôi hồi Nếu
chap 3 giờ lâu lắm rồi
nhà rồi bây giờ xem khác nhau tí thôi mà
ở đâu có thể khác nhau nhiều đấy chúng
mày đấy
cho anh nha
ờ ờ
ở blog này
em xem nhá
Ừ ai cũng được
không muốn hiển thị theo kiểu dạng kiểu
như này
khi gà mình nên cho bằng bằng bằng đến
nút mình dễ bấm sướng và hiển thị ra
kiểu trôi nổi trôi nổi cửa ngày trước
đổi kiểu này hợp với bài blog hơn thì ra
kiểu dạng của cô đắp nên xem cho rằng cô
rất nhé
a
black rồi
số trực tiếp
anh khóc đấy không có ở đây là rất khác
tôi xem thằng Trực tiếp đi
Em đừng có mà điện thoại trực tiếp luôn
xe lửa
blog cây này có file Cai
Anh ở mình có thể lấy đúng kiểu dạng
Nhanh nhỉ không cần ảnh bỏ ảnh đi
chị xem nhé hoặc là cái này cái này lại
phải có cần là background
chị nghỉ rồi xin mãi
sẽ bắt chước mấy cái đây
có sao đâu
mình làm thêm mình đen nữa
không chút nhé Ok
đâu Cái đắt mà
bí ngô nghĩnh đó người già à
nhưng mà hàng này hàng xịn chưa mà Long
cho hạng miễn phí cho
Hạnh đều
á nhon
em xin ấy
hồi Vũ chap 3 rồi nhưng nó vẫn xịn đúng
không
anh không Không được đâu
ừ ừ
a
web mà mình sẽ mình
thì mình sẽ có một hàng là thằng à
đ.tp
ừ hát đi cần
thủ loại mất rồi thì thôi Bạn đâu rồi
Happy Cần Thơ
à à
ở tp đúng
mày ngu vãi
ở với thằng cybertech gõ pp của đấy nó
sẽ ra thẻ người hãy tl à
Bây giờ tôi sẽ có tặng 1 lô tô trước nữa
đi vào
là đầu tiên đăng nhập chứ không mày kiểu
hiển thị trang điểm ngay à
ờ ờ ờ
nhỉ Cái
Rider này motor này sẽ có prefix
chú ý
à mà AD cực ở
Em về chưa ạ
có ai mình để hót cốt luôn được không
sao à
em mặc định rotor vào là
mặc định đầu tơ vừa vào của mình sẽ là
cậu
từ hôm Tết được ạ Mày tôi đã bảo là mình
sẽ làm hôm bếp à
Vì sao homepay của ap cân thì phải sửa
lại cái tên à
em có lưu ở đây
A Happy cân
A và
Ừ ok cái trang này gần như là Trang khá
quan trọng nên thích mình để riêng cũng
được Để xem nhé Để xem nhé
So sánh này bạn chất là có xuất tìm kiếm
này có ai giúp hiển thị ra nếu nếu cần
này
em sống tin cá nhân thì nó cần này con
cho do khác
Ừ cái tặng thì đã về sau sữa XO
ừ ừ
nhà mình có mặt hàng
chết này phải tạo ra ngoài tôi lỡ tạo
chết ở trong nhà nội tôi chết mình lên
có một thư mục riêng để chết à
xe Scoopy
đăng kí là gì
ở chung p a
à à
ừ ừ
I take a lô này
a stand-alone này
cho nên luôn extend caro
anh idol
a dọa giết thầy bồ
Ừ cái bộ ở đây không có gì cả Có khi mở
khóa hết mấy thằng này đi
vọng
à à
Anh yêu cái cần ở trên mấy trăm này
hay như nào cơ
không ạ nhà đầu tiên mình sẽ Return về
cái á
thì
mình sẽ có một cái để tôi xem nhé
lao này bản chất leo này thì đang đặt
tên nó lại phù hợp ở bên admin hơn
khi lao của nó posts
ừ ừ
a home page home page home page thì tôi
đang định làm đấy Tôi đang định làm đó
là mấy ông nhìn cái này hấp dẫn không ạ
Cái này tôi sẽ là file của bên A
khi mà hát rồi nhìn sẽ ở Copa của mấy
ông sẽ ra kiểu ngay nó có mạng xã hội
này chị đâu thì và giao diện nó sẽ giống
với kiểu là cũng hiển thị ra cả ba cái
ngay còn bên bài đăng Thế thì ba cái
nghĩa lấy ao một cái lao là lỗi out leo
này live support và một lao nữa lấy áo
của giản kiểu để mà
stun bây giờ nó leo kiểu
em có nên là để hiển thị ra giao diện ở
bên khách hàng chưa vào tay ai ở bên là
trang quản lý đạo đã boss là ra lại học
lại bình chánh quản lý cũng hiểu không
a nhớ xem nhé
ở những thắng cho mụn nữa
đấy thế nên là tôi luôn tôi nghĩ à anh
em luôn phải cứng nhắc của việc là tên
về sau mình sửa rất là nhà về tôi sửa
cái từ láy hàng đấy leo đã post thằng ăn
rồi Sửa nhiều chỗ
anh nghe sửa vẫn sửa thôi mà sẽ phải sửa
nhiều chỗ tôi lười sửa tạm để về
Vì sao này mình sẽ lao đặt tên à Ờ store
phan văn văn văn văn fanpage fanpage
diện thì máy hiển thị ra
chị xem nhé Vậy thế
cô này mày cái hết đâu rồi cũng chị này
khi trò
a lô
kết cả chán đầu tiên rồi
giao diện chợ nhà Hải nó sẽ giao diện
đúng kiểu nhé
chị sẽ có khách sạn tìm kiếm bên này
xong rồi Bên này thì chị ra Họ trông
giống hết ngay luôn nó đương nhiên cái
giữ làm cái bên này bị sẽ sửa lại theo
phong cách kiểu kia cái
anh không hiểu tôi
ông làm sao này trước đó tôi làm con em
nói chứ
à à
bộ trước trận này là
ý là tôi muốn nha
nữ
ca sĩ Xuân Này Hello quá xe container
vào đây
cho điểm A crab rồi mình sẽ chỉ lấy đi
grab ở đây Xóa Thằng ai đi sáng mai đi
đây này
Xóa ID xoay đi Xóa hết đi nhá phút ơi
tôi để lại nhỉ
- phái sassoon này Xóa đi sân bay đi anh
à Còn gì đâu
ở trên này hết đồ án hết đô
em hết đô của mình có hiển thị ra gì
không nha à
em hết đâu Mình để đi được nhỉ
Có mấy cái này thì nên có này
Ừ vợ chống chóng gọi mình sẽ tạm đây Cái
này ừ ừ
chị sẽ có đây à
thì mình sẽ có một thằng Master đúng
không ạ Master chấm
chấm TP
à à
em gái
I Pray mình sẽ có thể bỏ đi đấy à
I cấp II nó copy ra mình ba điện ok rồi
giỏi phết lại phải trả hết thì xóa bớt
sau trong body Heat hay có cả giá xu rồi
à
ờ ờ tiếp theo mình sẽ có hết
em copy hết
Ừ ok Cái này là bootstrap.min tokid này
a map api xóa map api đi xóa hai thằng
vớ vẩn đấy đi
bỏ qua mát ở
Ừ cái này là Navy Paul tính sau này
Anh tính sau tính sang mp3 nó có cái đây
mà footer này á
Ừ bác more Tại sao lại có khái niệm
rossmore anh ạ
xe máy
Ừ ok
ờ
ờ rossmore À nó ở đây những nv3 đây nó
bị sắp xếp và
bằng format bằng sáp AD Xem cắt bớt rồi
tivi format lại vậy tôi ở đây này I just
wish moment bỏ qua này
Ừ mai đô qua
Bỏ qua hết Nói chung là mấy cái này mấy
ông sẽ thêm sau
hi Speed control canxi cho Active Zippo
có thể hướng nhé Chắc cần Nếu mà thêm
một vài cái nữa bởi nó liên quan motor
riokid nhé kia
a Rado slime đúng aficionado trí nhớ cái
này à
Dù mai đây trên internet
ở nhà Ông thấy kéo nó nhìn thị ra cái số
này đấy tao dụng lại đâu đấy nhưng mà ở
thế kỷ tí cho bạn được cho được bắt buộc
phải có số bắt đầu xuống kết thúc đấy
rồi Mac mini nào Ờ xem nhé Ok slido có
thể tạm thời để đấy đúng không
khi mình xóa rồi Thằng này đâu rồi em
số đầu tiên này schleiden Ok nhớ giữ
nguyên thằng đấy Này xóa mấy thằng này
ok chưa
con gì không nhỉ
Ừ Ok tạm thời Thế
tiên vào cái trang này tôi tầm view
phẳng cái Master à
layouts
onepay đúng không ạ đã
tiên đã trông nha hôm pagecontrol này
này à
thì mình sẽ có Abbott cân này chưa này
Đầu tiên sẽ vào ngay ngoặc nó sôi cân
chưa ngủ đây Lấy từng cái thằng 11 em
yêu lại à
à bút chapman này nó
Em không biết được vào có giống hình như
nó vẫn cùng trùng chung với thằng Hải
đấy
Ừ rồi
vì vậy
ở cùng chung của cái thằng này
à à bút spa
Anh
không muốn xem
em có nghỉ
Ừ anh ấy không dùng bút cha mà lại
Ừ có gì nhỉ
à à
em không có luôn Sợ thật về rồi à
a Master Kids này
à à
ba ngày rồi kéo cũng vậy thôi
Nhưng mình có phim đi rồi Thằng kia
không dùng nữa chị
khi sex
không dùng này
này Không dùng này và
A Moment they're hai cái gì đó tính sau
lại đây
khi họ tặng bà đấy à
à à
mà nay lại dễ hiểu nhất rồi ông không
hiểu cái này nữa cái dễ hiểu hơn nghe
chị đến đàn là lái xe về đâu mà ừ
thì luôn nhớ rồi chưa biết luôn
có thể gọi cho
Ừ thôi xóa đi sang Đức
xem ra giao diện chưa đã
chú chó
chị xem nhé
ảnh bìa
Mà tại sao nó lại bị lỗi anh nhỉ
ở khách sạn chelpus được một thằng nào
đó rồi
thế này hay cho lỗi quá này
a Master Kids ren Ninh lại được motor
kit cho tới khi như vậy Bị lỗi à đấy
ngày tự như lưu lại đừng đừng dẫn này
à à
U20 cả lúc này chương trình mà à
ờ ờ Tiếp theo đi Chạy sang
I sleep đúng
có ai
đi xe độ đèn exit
ừ ừ
anh nói Apple chat
ca nhạc Bolero
à à
ấn tượng Thế mình có thằng ngày
Ừ Ok Sáng nay đi
a12 nữa hình như bây giờ mình sẽ lưu vậy
anh sữa
mà mất Alo Kids ngày thôi
à à
không nhỉ vì bạn
Ồ vãi cả tính năng à
xe tải postroll Trinh
một tay bút à
Ê mày tái bút anh nhỉ Phải chèn thêm về
nhé
Ừ Ok mày muốn chèn cho trẻ dùng tay
inbox trong chưa Mày thấy lạ à à
à à
em copy đại đi
cha không còn gì không Xóa blog cider
hai
người rồi à
đấy à
em có bị đoạn này có bị gặp lại tất cả
nhé em nghỉ lỡ Hình như dạo này tôi
không bị lặp lại nếu không khéo đang bị
đã ký kết này xem nhé
chị xem này không ở đây đúng không Alo
này đi
à à
em có một cái mà nhỉ Vì sao đây nó lại
hình hai cái nhỉ
Ừ chắc một talia trước 40 rồi hai cái
Facebook của tôi yêu này nhỉ Khi nào thế
nhỉ
em có nhiều kiểu gen gen đột biến anh
hay Thái được nghỉ à
ừ ừ
à à
có 2 cái à
trông thấy lúc đầu không có chỗ mà mới
tích thêm vào
Thu Hà tôi đã nghĩa có khi là do cái á
khi cây thai
à à
Ừ cái cái cái này nhớ cái demo vậy
hôm nay for from actual test của nho cái
daemon bỏ đi
mẹ nó rồi
cho con cái này Tại sao các tính năng
thú vị thế đấy nhỉ
ừ ừ
khi có sự thật
à à
bộ phim sex
anh em uống sữa thanh kéo đúng không
à à
cho iPhone g.đ
A và squat vào tay nó bị kiểu đã ký kết
thì phải nhìn chung bếp nhỉ
phải sao
Âm Nhạc
xổ số gì con sôi sửa lỗi ảnh thôi
khi nuôi con đi nữa
à à
ở công ty nhé lưu này ở đây
ở nhà lửa khác ngoài bị topic thằng ngu
về nó để cái cãi nhau ngay
vẽ trái nghĩa gì gọi cả để xem à
Em có chị nha
Ừ thế đã sửa sao được cái loại này sửa
nhanh được ngày tháng này chỉ đang đi
mua thôi mình để bắt mình có thể copy
code để mà sửa tự làm hạn tháng mới mà
353 Minh óc à
anh nói đùa nói bởi vì bạn chất là cái
cái HP pro rồi được tạo ra bởi Swift
mình chuyển là mình xóa được à
Ừ rồi tôi ấn à khi mà các bạn ấn copy
lên mình này thì mới các em mình này
được tạo ra bởi ra Switch Thành nó bị
lỗi như vậy rồi à
Ý chị nói em
ở anh mỗi ảnh hoa nữa có chỗ chứa được
không Mẹ đang này mình sẽ sẽ lấy từ bên
A
ở bên này nhé nào nhỉ
Ồ tôi thích cái này
chỉ vào rồi trị giá kiểu này cái nó sẽ
không biết những điểm đó là trên giao
diện điện thoại mà ông chỉ vào như này
rất khó chỉ nhưng thực ra bấm vào cửa
nhà nó hợp lý hơn nhưng mà
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà chị xem à Ừ tớ nghĩ cho Bấm
cái này cho xem nhanh nó bị hơn
Ừ tôi sẽ làm cái kiểu này trong vẻ hay
nhưng mà chị nào diện điện thoại ông
không chọn chuột rồi đi ngọn ông cùng
ngắm và ông giữ ông Nhấn vào nó không
giữ cái tay ở đấy thì may ra nó có những
cặp review video ở trên một vài trang
web video nhạy cảm có kiểu bấm vào thôi
giữ giữ tay rồi đấy nó sẽ cho review
trước không ạ nhưng mà
a bít người dùng biết ở điều này lắm đó
Vì thế nên là tốt nhất là mình có làm
thống nhất là mình làm thì cậu ngay hạn
chế kiểu dạng kiểu trải nghiệm người
dùng trên điện thoại khó chịu
Anh ở việc làm trên điện thoại hiển thị
nút khác thôi
không
a Master audio đấy
em có tiền cùng anh em như ti mua mà
chuyển
kể
chuyện cậu có sẵn đi
anh không Không có hàng có sẵn thì đâu
à à
Có ai biết rồi
em chấp nhận diện được của mình gọi nó
bị nặng quá
tất cả trước
Em hãy xã đến cái đít này
bộ phim hài
trả lại
ở đó
khi gặp mổ gà tháng năm mỏi hơi sai nó
phải đẩy xuống chứ không phải kiểu ngon
không nằm ở trong cái đít này nó đẩy
xuống cô ấy Mày hiểu dạng kiểu như này
bọn xông hơi buồn cười
bạn là sao Chắc chắn là nó có ra tay rồi
còn là
a file pay nhưng hàng phải ở trong
Facebook không dùng tay p đâu dùng cái
khác để còn không phải vậy đâu
anh Thái trồng kiểu đỡ hơn đúng không
à à
khi học sat 45 trong bị lệch
là do mắt tôi lại nhé
anh ạ
trông lịch nói chị nhỉ
à à
bộ phim sex thú sân bay này
chó sử classless nhanh
t-ara's nhanh ý
à à
dụng trong cái này à Có gì nhỉ flash
Drive
class Glass cho ai vậy mình đi tay vậy
à à
ừ ừ
Đúng vậy thôi
Ừ mình đi cắt lần lượt đây ở trang
Master mà
ở đầu tiên là từ ngã v30
ừ Địt container MP3 ở đây
này
em hết đâu rồi ạ ê
đ.tp
em gái
Ừ ok ờ
Em Mất Anh
Ừ rồi tiếp theo này à
cô đơn này
ở đây sẽ hết đô
đó tiếp theo mình sẽ có
a men ở đây Ở chính giữa không ạ lên ở
đây thì nội dung ở giữa ở đây
what you need Văn cái bên này bên xuất
ra thích kiểm yếu cũng bị tất ca nữa
phải bên sớt cũng được nó sai 30 ạ
mở ba sẽ là chính phải xa ba và cái còn
lại sẽ mới chí này không ạ
Đây Nghe toàn bộ Cái này
ở Sapa
say bà plex.tv
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok rồi đấy tiếp theo thì cái bên này
nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản mà
ở đoạn giữa này
chị sẽ cái xanh hiển thị thôi ông ạ
Ờ Ờ
để xem bé để xem nhé Ừ
mà do diện nó sẽ khác đựng to một tí
chả trang văn này
ở nhà ăn tết
16h rồi cũng sẽ dùng để trang này nhưng
mà mỗi cái mỗi mỗi cái size 3 lẫn cả cái
này nó sẽ khác
size 3 và cả ngày ok
anh xóa về mày đi
đặt tên nó là
impression P E
Ừ lát mò đấy Thực ra là
một mình à
thì mình nên dùng rossmore bị Phương
tranh nhỉ có nghĩa phân trang bạn nói tí
tôi sửa lại Nó Phương Trang kể tính sau
Ừ ok Bây giờ chuẩn bị lỗi cái bây giờ
cười vậy à
khi họ
Ừ chị mới nói cái vú to không
hết pin ở đây không còn cái thằng cha là
sao không ạ Cái rồi đấy đây
Ừ rồi
cho Nokia bây giờ mình sẽ in Plus lần
lượt thôi
chị bé Na
à à
ô tô này này
a tiếp theo
bộ phim sẽ có ừ đàng em mình phải làm
cái này lần lượt từng tháng một chứ
không phải ở đến bây giờ mình làm nha à
đi xe hay bị quên
post này thì mình sẽ lại làm theo kiểu
để có nhiều tài fast
anh nghe sĩ Quang Lập tuyệt include Hàng
ngày tôi sẽ đặt tên hài có poland tôi sẽ
đặt tên ở nhà cho mấy ông dễ hình dung
này
hi vọng sẽ biết thêm khái niệm nữa đó là
Blade II e và tâm thằng này đặt
component
không có nên như thế này
em đi tắm một con lợn
do mình sẽ
này
di truyền giá trị ở trong quân hành
Ừ Đợi thì đợi đi chúng em xem nha
mình để mà in ra trong Công an Nói cái
gì sử đây đây in chuyền chuyền chuyền
bạc
hình dung cảm ơn ân của Black là review
nó sẽ cầu cơ Vân chuyển nhé khai báo rồi
nhé Xin cảm ơn đền vào trong đấy
nhà thì mình tốt việc về sau mình bớt và
cái gì đó
kiểu cơ 2 kiểu HTML công cửa HM lại là
kiểu à
Ừ mẹ kiểu trong nó kiểu giảm
trang ví dụ đâu nhỉ
cơn mưa này nó sẽ mua cái giao diện nó
sẽ trông như này một cái nó sẽ thử trong
như thế này cơ Để xem nhé em nhé
Mình có thể chưa kiểu ở bên fan này
em không nên làm gì thế
ở thời trang cần em thị nó cân đổ vòng
lặp là để đổ vào cổ phần
con
anh nghe bài post và vì sao lá bài à
file thứ nó hai thằng khác Ok không
không không không ảnh hưởng gì đấy cả
kết
anh em mình sẽ có một cặp cá nhân cho
mày đi
I
make component không
chưa giờ làm tôi sẽ làm cho mình xem
luôn à
chết
I
make company
không
Dù mai sau mình sẽ copy cái này vào
trong này
ở nhà chọn
ờ ờ
ở đây mình sẽ có
mình sẽ sử dụng là
Em
định sẽ la poste nha Trưởng
ở ngõ chống vậy tơ 2
được à
vì nó không có cái gì mình truyền vào
trong nó còn hiểu chuyện và kiểu dạng
ngay cơ
sẽ là Ở đây có nên ở trong cái à
Ừ chắc
vì nó không nói mình khai báo ở đâu luôn
gọi xịn vai
anh em
khi video để nhé nick cô phân này là tạo
class
à à
cô gái sẽ sử dụng bữa nay
về bản chất khi mà con chắc và khi mình
truyền vào trong cái thời ấy truyền
trong tháng ngày mình chuyển ra data ạ
Ừ nếu không thể Cách Xa Bảo đây khi
truyền vào sẽ là
A2 chấm data sống mỗi như thế này
chấm data đây sẽ ơi
A Gọi ích chẳng hạn nuoc xem mình lấy từ
đâu
cho mình mình sẽ vòng lặp for ở đây này
anh không Master mình chưa làm Bọn mày
vội Đợi gì Cho mình chưa làm vụ này vội
I
thường con ten ở đây
à à
khi lao nha
em đổi đây gia sửa mình sẽ lấy bài đăng
ngọn có đây là code
Vì sao đó đây mình sẽ
để coi thằng ad cân
có
file crack chấm TP ở lại
em
A gọi là kiểu này đúng là như tự kỷ thật
nghĩa có bình thường Bây giờ đâu chấm
chấm TP I span ở đây Circle IELTS Master
nó thì mình có soon
content IS
ừ ừ
trầm index
à à
di truyền đây sẽ đạt post
xe
hơi Toàn bossnight
và đây mình sẽ có phối
post
anh
em phối cả đây
chị sẽ opening ngày nay sẽ chuẩn data và
những kiểu nhà luôn
ở đó
kiểu ngay cho mình xem
anh đi xe đạp điều hết
anh gọi nha ông lão đang không đi thời
gian bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
BD thằng này nữa nha và xem Đúng tất cả
bài đăng nha có tám mấy bạn mình này
hai cái gọi thằng ai à
em nói chuyện Ở đây Đúng rồi nghỉ
hay tôi Vứt vào trong hay sai nhỉ
đi bắt bò ở đâu mà được nghỉ
à à
biết được cái này vứt ở đâu luôn đấy
đoạn bút này
Em đang ở đâu nhỉ
gà con
ừ ừ
service provider
anh đánh xe buýt của Viber Đấy
you are doing
khi con heo nữa Sáng ngày rồi nè gì mà
aa12 hell
á nhon
khi diện nó hơi bị vỡ nhỉ
cho xem đại náo giao diện bị vỡ nhé
Trưng bùng phát ở
xe chính chủ cái nào
khi bé như này Tại sao nó bị à Cái bị
tràn à
Vì sao khiến nó ngày chả vậy
cố định luôn cả bộ này
khi sex
vậy
Ừ ông là nó đấy cố định đoạn này của tôi
làm nó bị như này
a style ở đây Vãi cả chuông cố định ạ
ngày cho đẹp
nhỏ nhất là như thế
Ừ nó xa lạ núi này đi à à
cho nó
anh xuống xóa
anh
đã bị tràn ra bị tràn là mấy ngoãn thứ
ba có thể sửa xe để tạo ảnh tránh tràn
được làm được
30 tối
anh có Xem nick ma rồi nhưng mà tôi tôi
xem đó rồi Xem chỗ nhiều lúc nào tôi
chẳng cái gì
Cho xem nhạc xưa cái này thì rộng ra
được mà nhỉ
thì
tại sao bạn lại tự như bé lại nài nỉ đi
pro Sun Red
một tiệm bánh à
Ừ tao container bé nghỉ à
mở đèn pin mà
anh nhớ cái này cho bé nghỉ luôn
CS over
ờ ờ
Ừ đợi tí sử dụng sự trợ giúp của cốt ở
trên công ty
với nhớ tôi từng là với vụ này rồi à
à à
thế này xịn
anh như WiFi gọi được đấy
bộ phim cá đây sẽ là ăn kết
hiểu mình dùng flash này sẽ ăn Tết
cô gái phim sex chung kết rồi đấy ạ
chú chó
vì vậy
Cho tôi xem ảnh cái khác rồi
xem nha à
e k Vân
em lắm mà không lên trai
đang chạy dễ quá rồi phải dạy khó hơn để
anh anh em không thấy cuốn
ừ ừ
ở nhà bị mất Ok Xem hình súng CF như thế
nào để cam kết
mà
à à
á nhon
good job đ
Ừ chắc 3 cơ mà thích ăn kết em có nha
I acted like luôn chị thật
cờ tướng
ừ ừ
anh đi rồi
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này 400 400 Năm đúng
không nó bịt tôi
vì nó có được rồi có được vậy
anh ạ
từ ngày sản xuất
anh không
Ừ không thì chơi cái kiểu nông dân
10 cách không cần Vì sao chúng ta phải
với vợ anh ơi con mệt mỏi
Em nhìn anh không nhìn họ tập đây này
Ê bà cái đúng không
á nhon
gì tôi copy tôi thử cho Hạnh post bài
đăng có cái gì dài không nhỉ
Đó là bài Trót mình chẳng có gì dài cái
thứ Tại sao nãy giờ mình phải là bọn này
nhỉ Mình là người có decrease đâu nhỉ
Đợi đi
thị ra cái này phải post anh nghỉ đi vào
để dài cả à
nghe có đoạn này ra dài đúng không
dài đúng không Đúng chưa
ừ ừ
Ừ anh ở Bình thường ở trong ngày đúng
không
Này thì thằng level nó cứ cho là kiểu
cắt chuỗi rồi biển trỗi hàng cái gì đó
này
à Mình dùng Donald
Tôi dùng CS để cố hạn chế không làm kiểu
này thôi không thích mình làm cả ngày
được giới hạn ký tự ở được mà anh kiểu
nhà này
nữ streamer như này chứ tối đa chị ạ mấy
dòng Thôi xong nghĩ nhiều
cho ví dụ nha
Em hãy copy các loại mày vào
cả ngày đúng không
à à
ở đó
thông tin cần Duy ở mấy cái kia màu mè
đoạn của tôi sẽ luôn đến 20 rồi nó sẽ
ngắt thành-dầu 3.0 phải do cuối ngày mai
trời mưa nhé
tình yêu của ba trăm mấy rồi mà thể thay
nó bằng mỗi ký tự khác hiểu dạng ký tự
cuối là cái gì tùy nếu đặt xong
muốn thu sét để nó kiểu tự động ngắt hộ
mình nhưng mà ạ Nếu mình không biết sẽ
thì mình chơi vòng TP
ngon
gì đàn bà
nói chút là thứ tôi quên mất rồi Cái này
cũng chẳng cần của mình cũng giúp hay
thôi chả có cái gì để hiển thị ghê gớm
rồi ai cả
xe Honda có cái gì Hồ
thằng có một cái gì để nghị nhiều ý
AE nhập thấy thô này Ờ language thì sẽ
đi ra này Company Nếu có này khi con gì
đâu anh thì chẳng còn gì cái bạn này cho
thai thôi đúng không cái đoạn mà trí Cáp
này nó là cái đoạn này hay thu nữa đúng
không Hai thùng nữa này sẽ là
ngôn ngữ này sẽ ngôn ngữ đi được
à
khi gà nút này rồi thằng muộn nút này nó
ở một góc thôi bị sẽ tận dụng ở đây có
vai cái nút khác để hoa các logo khác để
mình thì chị ra Kiểu kiểu như này tôi
thích kiểu như này có cái nút ở đây rồi
mà Xoay cái nỗi gì đó Xoay đây chẳng hạn
còn bên này sẽ alo cô công ty này tên
công ty này nếu kiểu không sẽ làm như
thế
xem nha a terrace xoay xoay cái gì mỗi
sai rồi
sẽ có một cái photo ở đây không phải đi
ông cho lấy ngon copy cái đít sau này
biết sau này quan trọng này à
à à
Ừ anh sẽ là Style flash
I read ngon ơ
anh hỏi thằng ngày một hàng size
flashlight nó sẽ trôi lại sáng phải thôi
đúng không ạ
anh cho thằng Dâu tươi bé lại này to quá
a feelin proud root
root cái gì chẳng biết
khi trở về
anh tin em có tình small thôi
à à
một ngày thôi
ừ ừ
cô gái gọi Bé Bé
em
nói đi
có thằng em mới sang được
ừ ừ
gì sai đâu
mất công
có cái gì thì nó xoay nào
sang
anh trực tiếp nipple whipple tất cả cái
thằng này tại Little One Nguyễn Trúc do
sai ý
ừ ừ
chú chó
anh alo
ra Suối đấy ạ
ô hay bị lệch đúng không Nếu không rõ
ràng thấy thôi bị lệch đúng không ạ
anh ạ
ông Tống nó vào bên trong luôn nhỉ
ở xã hội bị lệch
khi bé nhỉ
Em email
nâng thứ nhất là của Exciter
Exciter đi này à
ừ ừ
lúc đầu cái này như nào nhỉ
anh cứ tốn ga nồi làm nó diện mày quá
ở bên anh
ừ ừ
à à
ở các thành phố ở đây
xe ô tô login top
ở lại chung giá bình thường không ạ
I start lại
Mở đồng hồ
khi chấm
có thể dùng mỗi ngày nha à mỗi ngày nha
à à
Ừ ừ
nó cái nút nút này nó làm cho
mới qua
tôi cũng chán thêm đúng với đoạn này vào
Ừ anh sẽ ổn mọi thứ sẽ ổn thôi
I like
cô gái tên đúng nhỉ
ghi
khi sex
á nhon ấy
a flashlight bị mất Flashlight
chị Thu cho mấy phải đi mình Martin đúng
không mẹ chồng Baggio chửi mày không
Em chào anh ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Anh đúng là tên là ngoại smút
Ok mẹ tặng
nó đỡ khó chịu được giao diện đã được ra
tôi có thể Tống em nếu tự sự này
cho đỡ mệt à
Ừ
ok lại khá là mình
ở đây mình có thai thô
Bây giờ tôi sửa ngang đoạn này trước khi
khóa giờ cũng mấy ông
truyền ở đây mày Ông thấy à mình chuyển
ở đây cái đó post này không ạ sẽ lấy
được post ở trong này à
như nào sản phẩm này mình truyền vào đây
kể chuyện ở đây Messi cho mình nhỉ nghệ
sĩ thật đây garip mai ship today in a
message ok ok
vì thế tất cả mình đây một cái đô la
poste ngay đúng gọn cho mình sẽ báo đây
này sẽ báo thấy topic Ok mình sẽ để
public Sẽ Về Hai Thôn này
chẳng hạn như thế sau đây mình sẽ đôla
ĐT đồng hồ bằng loa Bose đến hay thô
nặng thế ngoại sau đó thì ở đây mình
sẽ lại đây
menu các thứ này anh hay khô
ở nước ngoài doris
em chuyển dos là đúng rồi nhỉ ta tên là
đây sẽ support
ở tập thế
hợp mà ở đây drop facial karaoke Lỗi tội
lỗi Tôi rót hai hồ à
Ừ nó chưa xin được ngon logo 96 ngồi
tính sao
tiếp theo
a tiếp theo cái này này như tôi bảo nó
sẽ là cái ngôn ngữ
từ ngôn ngữ
ở đội to một tí nhá
anh ở đây à
Ừ anh có bí kíp sinh biết cách Trân chắc
à còn à Ờ ok các ngôn ngữ các cuộn ừ
cả các ngôn ngữ thì mình sẽ có object
language cho mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ áp Chắc
lại toàn bộ những cái language
ý của bài post này đi kèm thì tức à
anh giờ đây đợi tôi tí nữa chị em với
ông nhé và bản chất là khi ở ông truyền
này không sợ phải hít thêm một cái là ờ
thì sẽ báo trong này Đoạn này đoạn phức
tạp đấy mình tập trung ý đấy
về bản chất nha mình chất là thằng này
thằng cốt này có nhiều cái language
không ạ Họ sẽ thông qua cái hai chúng
gia mà chị lấy toàn bộ language ông ạ
Thì cái này nó sẽ là nếu mà cha của Lara
này
Ừ tự nhiên đến đoạn này em xúc tại mới
phức tạp thì các em ấy ông sẽ hơi choáng
thì loạn lại đăng chuẩn bị ỉa à
Anh bình thường ấy Bình thường nếu mà
một khoa nhiều thằng thì sẽ onetomany
này nhưng mà vì là thông qua thằng trung
gian thì nó sẽ là Harmony Pu nghĩa là
thông qua họ trung gian nữa nhưng mà ở
đây lại còn thêm một cái nữa đó lại là
nó là dạng là thế Ông thấy là ngày nó sẽ
cho rằng mà
ở đó là hai tức à
cho tất cả kiểu mình mình kiểu là có lúc
ở bài đăng có lúc là bài gì đó nữa mình
sẽ là kiểu hướng trị trừu tượng hướng
nhiều hơn đối tượng em thành ra là mình
sẽ
thì mình sẽ phải đổ phải chơi cậu hướng
Tính đa hình ở đây nó dùng từ đá hình
đấy Và one-to-many ở đây là many-to-many
phu như thế này ai nó sẽ có giống kiểu
bài đăng này video này tác này đều thông
qua thằng tác này nó sẽ là web mình bài
đăng đầy đủ ngon và thông qua sẽ đúng
kiểu như này nó sẽ thông qua như này ai
vào xem thử bài đăng nó sẽ cấu trúc và
kiểu như này cơ
tôi sẽ copy cái này nhé
là web này
kỷ
niệm cứ đặt tên là ngay đi
Ngày Nếu mà như này nó sao biết được
thằng nào trúng gian nghỉ
see More
từ 2,3 tên đúng kiểu nhà nghỉ
nhiên hài thì chết
thấy buồn
gọi nha à
à à
anh nói chưa thử với bộ váy đâu tiên cho
thấy xem được không
Ê con kia
con kia đây à Mình sẽ đặt ở đây là
chị đã hết rồi
gì Thôi Như Thế các cô này
nhà mình có gọi đến tắt vô này vì sao
không
em hãy cho anh nhắn tin tao vô đâu cả
anh nữa
à à à Gọi VSIP để tắt nguồn thấy chẳng
thấy báo đâu bạn nữa nhỉ
a carryboy đi ừ
ở đoạn này
chị Hạnh tôi sẽ with về nhà của ít theo
với Thằng này đúng không chuyển hàng
ngày tôi sẽ có khái niệm và dê như thế
này cho mình xem đi
à Có sao Fonepad
Ô thế mình sẽ phải ạ
the first ở lại đi
à à
trẻ sốt có lấy đâu nhỉ bởi vì sợ thằng à
mày đang ngày không có
126 đây có
chị sẽ ra
à à
số
126 nhé Nó sẽ có
Mẹ Maria
à à Bieber
Khi mình mở đi bất ba rồi nhỉ
đi mất tư vấn em đi bồ lên để mà lấy
được câu chữ vấn
thế này nó sẽ ở như thế này
mở ra ngay lên này nó thì ông D cả hai
ông sẽ lấy được toàn bộ câu truy vấn
nghĩa là chạy cái này xong sẽ lấy câu
truy vấn cho mấy ông như thế này
lấy toàn bộ test
U21
một cái là
a a track ID
add ID
chính là ID
được bỏ qua tất cả những câu sau đề ID
bỏ qua hết
I
watch 2
Em Không Tin
ở cột tăng pic 2 Infinite vệ sáng
nó thêm luôn thêm chữ s à Luôn Thêm chụp
hai và cho tôi và nó sẽ bằng cái này ok
ok
Ơ cái thằng leo nó làm cho chế nó lưu
lại sinh trong này tôi không muốn lưu
lại rồi đấy thì tôi không biết là tôi đi
thêm kiểu này được không
Có ai đi này Sau đây tôi sẽ ghi là kiểu
i5 thì mình làm 5 là
Cơ Học Chất language hai này à
đi chuyệ nó dạng như này
à Dạ post hiểu được nó là một
thì tại sao
mình sẽ đổi đặt tên là nó là thay thôi
em được không nha à
à à
can stay
anh luôn mặc định thêm chữ thay cho mình
ạ và luôn gạch dưới này lỗi Ngoại trưởng
Ê bà không Hi mình nó lại gọi đến thằng
language này
chị
xem nhé
cho ngày tết
a Witch
nó bị biến thành language này một cái
post này
Ừ thế thằng ba hình của thằng lauriel
này đang làm theo cơ chế nó hơi say rồi
Không đúng lúc đầu tôi muốn rồi mẹ bắt
buộc ở Mình lưu lại phải lưu lại cậu
dạng này trong tao bây rồi nếu lại dạng
kiểu nó chỗ như này
A và phải thêm một cái nữa là tên nó hót
hay như này nữa
the bell witch hay object
kit-2
sửa lại code này đỡ thông tin nhanh
không à php Xuân
Em à mai vậy
Crew
2 in hot czech language Apple
à à ừ ừ
lại
mình sẽ có czech language
ở nhà trọ lên say I
a12 đây đội nón Sun đ
em không có Devil Master
à à
Vì sao được
Ừ nó xài rồi
anh xóa tôi xin phép đội cái này
I
work làm thì nó về lưu lạc như này cơ
hôm sau tôi sẽ sửa lại cái vụ mà
từ hôm sau tôi sẽ trở lại vội leo bữa
nay sau nhé
đang ở chỗ nào cái đi lại đúng mới được
em gái
à À quên đổi tên nữa nhỉ đổi tên nữa
Ừ không sao không sao mình sửa lại trong
cốt là được
à à
thì mình sẽ win em
em làm từ cột này sang cột và optic 2i
à Còn chuyện nữa à
bộ phim sex hai cái cùng lúc
là sao
anh đã không ảnh hưởng gì
bộ truyện Chuyến Về rồi
xóa trong mai vô trường đi à
ạ Bây giờ người ta lại cho
ờ ờ axit language of Stick 2 và
bây giờ mình à
Đã thế lại không cần nữa bạn này là thay
Tao chích 2
một lấy tất cả bài đăng không ạ Hay là
lấy toàn bộ language này kèm theo
thế này bằng web bằng cách này
cả ngày lễ tội inna trong cái ông nói
ông xem nhé
ở đây mình sẽ có D1 đây có thể một hàng
thôi nhà mình như thế lấy luôn được post
gọi đến toàn bộ language của nó nếu có
chị sẽ là như này
ừ ừ
không
Nó sẽ có 2 language là Switch này ngon
chưa nên như thế này nó xịn ngoạn cái nó
sẽ cho Nối chung thông qua thằng trung
gian này để lấy được ngôn ngữ của mình
này à
Ừ ok chưa
Sau đó thì ở bên này mình à
ở bên B này
ở bên anh
em nằm nhiều biết mà Cái này mình sẽ có
là một cái Android bộ tất cả language
ngay
bộ phim sẽ có post này gọi đến language
Ừ
để xem nha
mình cần
Không cái này vẫn là phải xinh mình in
ra chuỗi chứ nhỉ
cho xem
anh ở đây ở đây Tôi muốn xử lý ở file
không có xử lý vòng lặp ở đây mà tôi cần
Đây là chuỗi ngôn ngữ ở đây mình sẽ là
toàn bộ Cái này nó xảy ra là dặn
rồi này
anh
Mạnh anh em mình còn lại mỗi lên này
mình cần lấy nêm mình sẽ blog
bộ phim sẽ Club
vì vậy mỗi nêm này
sau đó thì nó
contreras mình lấy nó ra hình dạng Mạnh
thật đó mình sẽ nối Nối cái mạng này
cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy cái cảnh như này
nhà trưng bày xuống
hình ảnh mới mới hiểu được cái đoạn này
nó sau đó thì mình sẽ in the language ở
trong 2U
à à
à à lỗi rồi lỗ tôi ai làm file để bikini
đi
à à
language không bị ra mình có thể ở chơi
trò là
Không những thế cho trò là lettuce như
này để lấy những cái bài gần đây nhất
Ừ nó
để lắp lắp để làm gì bắt mà bạn chất đấy
bản chất cả language Vừa rồi tôi in ra
trong mấy ông xem ấy thì nó là cái Dạ
nhà đấy
đến language cho mình xem nhé
nhầm xe mày còn chất là nó là một
Collagen và trong này có nhiều ở item
nhiều nhiều cái thằng đúng không Và
Ừ nếu mà tôi tour như này thì ông sẽ dễ
hơn này à
à à hình ảnh thì nó sẽ là có những cái
cột những cái cột và ID name và file
word hãy nhiều cái nữa đây đúng không
Con lắc nó chỉ nó sẽ chỉ trích xuất cái
cột nào mà Mấy ông muốn thôi Nhưng thấy
em chưa gặp mà cuộc lên mày không ngon
một là ông làm Blog stores Hay là ông Tô
Royce ông dùng cái ha mà có lum Thì ông
ấy mỗi cột nêm thôi cũng đủ
có ai Có 2 cách để tôi thử sử qua đây
nhá Sao tôi thấy ai có luôn để lấy mỗi
cột nêm cũng được có rất nhiều cách để
làm
lý do sử Mấy ông không biết bắt là cái
gì ngắm thể chơi vẫn ngay đó thì nó sẽ
ra hiểu ngay
Ừ ok chưa hoặc cả ông tôi thường hay
dùng mà tôi sẽ dùng cái lắc như thế này
Ừ ok
dành cho sciglio nghĩa là có nhiều cái
thì phải từ từ nó mới thấm không ạ Chứ
nếu mà kiểu ông mới học L'Oreal nhìn
nhận này công nhận nó Lũ thật ngoạn
nhưng mà giả sử mà ông cốt thật sướng
cốt liddell rồi khẳng định nhiều không
biết mày cái này này là tối chị mày ông
cái này để mày không biết được Sino nó
sẽ cốt như thế nào không ạ
ở
đó sẽ ra kiểu ngay đúng không Đây mình
sẽ sửa lại nhớ là mình sẽ lấy mình sẽ
lấy kèm theo cả logo của kompany nó có
hoặc Nếu có trả nợ thế
mình sẽ with Company ở trong này
nhà mình có thể cậu phải luôn ở đây
nhưng mà chắc là hôm nay Bộ mày khá dài
được trả hôm nay tạm thời Thế này đã Bố
sau tôi sẽ làm tiếp và hiển thị thêm
thôi Cái hợp và tìm kiếm và mình ông nhé
Tại sao nó lại bị ngay thôi Đậu Hải
thằng ngu si anh ạ
cái nhỉ
bị ngủ chưa nhỉ Hình như là có gì sai
đấy
anh như là đợi thích
nó về đó nha size 3 sẽ là sẽ
này
khi mẹ bị thế Đợi tí nhé
à à
anh đi Vậy à
này trước thì tốt nhỉ khó chịu quá
Ừ chị thấy Hà ngắn gọn này không nghỉ à
thì chả tác dụng gì
Vì sao làm lọ này nghỉ
đi Ừ
anh trước mà à à
a chance to nhắc đến cái vụ chết bóp anh
nha à
ô
checkbox này tốt hay Facebook một tô rô
này
mình chết Bắc không nhỉ
sữa bỉm
hoặc không muốn bỏ cuộc Lại mất tiêu rồi
kit thì mô
em có nhiệm vụ để mô này nữa
ngày à ừ giờ này
Ừ ok
khi chúng ra chơi cổ nay
khi nghe phật
cái gì mà gửi
chị nha
anh nói chuyện nó thành như này
anh mất cải
a route thêm cái đoạn này bạn này bị
biến hình như rồi ạ ảo thế nhỉ
có gì đấy
có thể thấy được
a dollar x
anh chết luôn cả bắt đi coi
à à
Vì sao mà áp rốt
cả ngày không có ai có mà ở
Vì sao không bấm rồi nhỉ
mày ông trả khích lệ của Buồn vãi
em
im read code card
à à
xịn nhưng mà
chết bóp
Facebook mình bị lỗi ạ Cái
ở đảo mãi xin hiểu sao mình kì I
em ạ
A8 input text input mỗi S4 trường hợp
nhất mình tăng lên bút
không nên sửa cốt không kiên mày ông là
nên chưa trò sẽ cốt là tôi đang muốn thử
xem mà giá code này đi đoạn nào nó sẽ bị
hỏng
những cô nàng với ba này
xe bọc Hoa Thiên Cốt
a-class về
a nice
số 1 phố vơ
ở ngã bảy open
mà
tại sao lại thêm đặt hai cái đấy nhỉ à
à à
ừ ừ
cái gì vậy chỉ nên dùng Internet
Explorer này
sản xuất với chân xuất Trinh
Tải Google Maps
I make up scenes
vì nó không cần mát lắm
Ừ cái gì không không dùng xoài đi
a comeback opmart hoa Xóa đi
à à
anh ạ
a no Sido
à hay là Sido là làm ảnh hưởng nhỉ
họ không ảnh hưởng lắm
Em hãy Pico
à huhu
nào tự nhiên làm đáp I kết của mình lấy
được cái thế nhỉ
à à
ra có nhiều cái trò mày không hiểu chưa
trò là bắt à bắt sự kiện của les vào
trong này nhớ là có một cái vụ mà có đơ
hay cái gì đó bắt sự kiện để biết được
và bản chất là cái này nó được tạo ra
bởi thằng nào có cứ nhớ kiểu gì cũng sẽ
có cái vụ bắt sự kiện
rồi nó mới ra cho nó được tạo ra bởi ra
swift không ạ à
này tạo một cái kích hoạt cái thằng nào
đó rồi thằng khác tạo cơ
Ừ nếu hiểu cho
Bí Ẩn Hoài Nha à
chị đã thì bị mất này nghỉ à
Anh xóa cái gì đó à
anh
mất luôn
cố của tôi rồi
sẽ mất
À nhầm gì đâu nhỉ À
à à
Ừ cái nhỉ
Mở bản đồ
em nói đi
chạy rồi đi
phố rồi nhỉ
có mùi vãi chưởng bảo sao
em xóa đi
khi rẽ đảm bảo Ngọc
Anh
ừ ừ
Ừ
thôi nghỉ mệt quá khả giọng rồi Không
biết hôm nay mình đã dậy những cái gì
nữa Điên mất thôi tạm nghỉ á Thôi cho
anh không
cả ngày còn mệt hơn Đúng rồi làm giao
diện còn mới hơi ở làm cốt bác em hóa
mệt
không lắm
con